und das wochenende wird ja auch bei uns
hier in deutschland fast überall richtig
heiß und warm
er birgt auch gefahren für uns werden
dann alle wieder sorgloser ja diese
sorglosigkeit können wir ja nur indem er
solche interviews machen und von anderen
stellen auch ermahnt wird sich an die
regeln zu halten
die haben wir geschaffen die sind ja da
die sind ja auch wirkungsvoll
das sieht man ja auch als dann endlich
mal die maske getragen wurde und die
politik auch erkannt hat hoppla die
maske ist doch nicht falls ja am anfang
dieses jahres wäre alles blödsinn da
sind auch die zahlen nach unten gegangen
und das ist das einzige da brauchen wir
gar nicht mit anderen nummern zu kommen
denn wir haben nichts anderes
und der abstand den wir immer haben
wollten den können wie eben nicht immer
herstellen und deswegen müssen wir immer
wieder daran erinnern dass die
schutzmaßnahmen
es bietet auch keiner mehr vom
händewaschen nebenbei gesagt ja
händedesinfektion das hängt überall
haben wir von anfang an gesagt
händedesinfektion ist das einzig
wirksame kann man auch überall machen
überall steht nicht ändern aber nicht
über ein waschbecken
also insofern wir müssen immer wieder
erinnern ermahnen und natürlich auch da
wo es eine gesetzliche vorschrift gibt
dann muss die ordnungsbehörde
durchgreifen bei denen die sich eben an
die regeln nicht halten und damit die
anderen gefährten fördert dann die hitze
ja die ausbreitung des corona virus ist
das besonders gefährlich jetzt wenn es
heiß wird
also ich denke nicht dass das temperatur
abhängig ist bist du unsere
körpertemperatur ist 37 grad
wenn dem virus 37 grad nicht gefallen
würde dann würde es hier in unserem
körper auch zugrunde geht also diese
theorie bitte mit der temperatur die
zeitlich und außerdem ist es so dass wir
in der freien natur das virus gar nicht
finden es ist nur da wo der mensch eben
gerade war wo er jetzt ist woraus atmet
aus hustet niest tröpfchen verwaltet und
wo der mensch nicht ist da gibt es eben
dass wir uns auch nicht weiß da mal
einer vorbeigelaufen leute sein sollte
dann ist es nach
ganz kurzer zeit auch tot bzw auch in
einem bereich wo der mensch ja auch
nicht mehr hinkommen wir griechen ja
nicht mit der nase über den fußboden und
saugen das corona wasser und in der luft
bleibt das nicht lange es hält der
schwerkraft gemäss einfach der tröpfchen
zu boden und damit ist die gefahr auch
gewarnt